sur une bande de bâtards juste une
petite vidéo pour vous annoncer la
sortie de notre nouveau fils d'un
nouveau film justement le calme ou stèle
de notre côté du périph
en fait c'est un monstre alors si avec
nous et laurent lafitte symptômes au
noir la flûte
c'est là que nouveau film on s'est mis à
faire de vous présenter aussi nous avons
marché dans l'ensemble du secteur des
jeux neufs des sceaux mais voilà tu vois
moi non pourquoi vous montrez là mais je
ne suis pas idiot et dans l'enzyme tma
dans ce film là mais ça c'est tout ça
tiens moi c'est non mais fermement
attendez je dois me croire les trois
jeunes hommes
mais c'est fini sur le 19 eh bien il
faudra maintenant nous allons aider dans
une scène frère si tu veux on est
peut-être de là